Five Nights at Freddy's is inspired by
the look and feel of a true life Terror
Charles entertainment cheese AKA
chuckecheese that place of business is
ostensibly where a kid can be a kid but
it's also where kids can be scared of
the giant creatures singing at them
while they eat pizza and cake and play
some ski ball the family entertainment
center delighted and haunted countless
children celebrating their birthdays in
the 70s ' 80s and '90s it still exists
today but in a much more stripped down
version unlike Freddy fazbears Chucky
never experienced any killer bite of 83
scenario even if the fan base has tried
to link some truly tragic events that
happened at chuck-e-cheese's into the
lore of FNAF in real life Chuck-E-Cheese
did start phasing out its own
animatronic band in 2017 just 2 years
after the FNAF movie was first announced
even if that decision wasn't officially
related to Freddy's the timing is still
spooky enough to make you think twice
about ever stepping into a
Chuck-E-Cheese ever again